[Music]
yeah you see what i'm saying
why i hate this map you see what i'm
saying why i hate this map
i'm peaking an angle they can be on top
of five different
there's too much crates it's the most
universally hated map in
all of it if it's icebox i'm gonna i'm
gonna
puke in my mouth i'm looking over here
gotta look up here
look at how many places i could get shot
from bro
i hate icebox and there's nothing else i
want to play on icebox
but for some reason one man has always
loved icebox
shroud this map's so good man i wish all
the maps were like this
so good ice box is the most divisive map
in the game
but it's also actually the most
important map in
ballarat
a bit of a flank coming over this is
also going to try to make his way in
finds the first kill a bit of panic but
things will calm down for just a moment
now a 1v1 raison ray
showstopper last pack over the top no
asuna blindly
takes down thief space to work with post
one as well
as that i'm all over the top he gets two
shuts out
again he did it yesterday and here he is
once
more phase might be gone next that would
be oh my god
that's
he's had enough of this [ __ ] oh my lord
four kills
looking for the ac that's it this time
that was
so there are a lot of reasons why ice
box is the most hated map in valorant
people hate the way it's designed the
way it makes you play the game the way
it launched with a bunch of stupid bugs
b snowman where's kitchen
b kitchen oh this
but over the last few months icebox has
actually become kind of an
underdog in fact it might just be the
most important map in valorant
shortly behind that uh is tens he's got
the frenzy
and he's got a kill man all up and moves
his face and he's getting a jumping one
as well on the thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it he's got
four he's going hunting for the ace
let him off the leash he's digging it
when icebox hit valorent in october 2020
people were dying to get their hands on
a new map but
things didn't exactly go as planned all
right i want you to watch me clear this
this site okay i'm looking at the zip
line i'm looking over here gotta look up
here
look at how many places i could get shot
from bro
you see on a map like icebox it takes a
little bit of a different approach
where if you're peaking onto a site
let's say a for example you're gonna
have a million different areas where you
have to look for so it's a little bit
more luck based but who doesn't want
luck in a skill based shooter this map
is horrible
and in december when first strike
finally gave us our first look at pro
play on icebox things only got worse
see everyone had already decided that
icebox sucked but there was this hope
that
maybe just maybe the pros knew how to
make this dog [ __ ] map look good spoiler
alert
they didn't see taking the aggression
straight to
immortals is benefiting envy marvelously
well so far
mummy loves that area we see him working
the pipes there in a
over and over again just feels so
confident vibing on that round as he
picks himself up with 3k
and a seems to be on lockdown now
or envy won't expect it and it won't be
stacked one of these times or any three
there though for envy it's gonna be a
quick trade and retribution kill they're
coming in we're on round
number nine here we have not seen any
aggression even towards beat i don't
think they've even put utility
on that side and it's been envy pushing
through b
more towards that crane and again
immortals setting themselves
up to look towards this a side thousands
of viewers tuned into icebox's pro debut
to watch immortals hit a sight against
enfie for 12 straight rounds
they spent their entire attacking half
just trying to brute force their way
onto sight
they didn't even look at me immortals
managed to muster up five rounds with
their puggy playstyle but ultimately
they
lost the game they didn't win a single
round on the defending side and nobody
could understand what the hell they just
watched
dash i'll be letting you know now i
thought i was going crazy man immortals
they went
a for like the first i said okay
they're gonna leave space to go to b
that didn't happen at all
the first thing we see is immortals go
12 rounds on a
um that's not really a good start for a
map see even though envy sent some token
defenders to b
they focused almost all of their
attention on a and it wasn't long before
other teams realized just how hard it
was to defend the site
and i watched immortals and their whole
game plan on icebox was for their jet
and rita to just walk up a
contact fight no abilities just dry walk
at bay
take fights and it worked for them
because of the way the maps design like
our teams aren't punishing obviously
like i think the best place with an off
but they're literally just contacting i
feel like that's just taking away
from the like skill set of the game like
you know there's all these cool
abilities and stuff
and you've got teams just running into
the site running into the site like
there's no
like map control nobody cares about
anything else they're just reforcing it
all right let's back up a bit why
exactly does everyone hate icebox
well there are a lot of reasons but at
the top of the list is
quite simply its size and layout
rotating is an
absolute nightmare for defenders by the
time you've made it onto the other side
of the map
chances are the attacking team has
already taken control of the site and
planted the spike
and as an attacker good luck trying to
fake your opponents out
there just isn't enough time to show b
and then rotate a
usually all you can do is just brute
force and commit yourself to one side of
the map just like immortals did
but once you and your teammates finally
make it onto sight things only get
worse the verticality of both bomb sites
makes it hell when you're trying to
clear the countless corners
but for attackers the real problem is
mid
you can't really like play mid or work
mid
compared to other maps um a lot of maps
don't even have a mid like bind
it doesn't even have like mid um like
haven
uh like at least you can like walk up
there lurk it or something it's a little
bit harder in icebox
you have to wait out a wall you have to
throw a lot of smokes you also have to
pressure the extremities because like
they're just gonna push you if you don't
like you can come up with creative
splits and like in theory
they look cool but you notice that no
team is really
using mid or the tube or spoiler in any
unique way
without the ability to assert mid
control on attack every other problem
icebox has gets even worse it's harder
to rotate
harder to fake and harder to feel
confident and take your time when you're
clearing out a sight
so with the middle of the map basically
off limits hull teams could do was hit
each site head-on
and we all know how that went but
despite all of its glaring issues
there was one person who absolutely
loved icebox
one man who didn't see it as a disaster
but instead
saw the coolest map in the game shroud
this map's so good man i wish all the
maps were like this
so good shroud's vct watch parties
brought in
thousands of viewers and he constantly
told them just how important icebox was
to pro play
the good takeaway about having such a
strong icebox is
it's kind of just like in counter-strike
in counter-strike it was really
important to have a strong menu
because ready to move on as he charges
um if he had a strong nuke
matt fans and picks weren't so
predictable so
basically if t1 can continue to have a
strong icebox
people will um they already have the the
map pick advantage because
people will always ban it always so
they're they could always predict
everybody
like we did the first game that's the
good thing about having a nice job
like a good ice box it's like having a
good nuke now it's up to curry gives you
that advantage for maps and bands and
stuff
picks and bands for them so did shroud
change the hearts and minds of millions
is he the reason people suddenly realize
that icebox was the secret best map in
valorant
i'm it's just i i
hate ice buck i hate ice box and there's
nothing else i want to play on ice block
it's impossible it's impossible it's
literally impossible to retake that side
and i'm not gonna go iron i'm not gonna
be ironic
as long as it's not icebox we win
the community still hated icebox but
riot couldn't just get rid of it they
had to change it to help it reach the
potential that people like shroud always
knew
it had patch 1.14 fixed some ridiculous
omen bugs but most importantly
both sites changed making it easier to
attack either of them
players no longer had to clear an absurd
amount of angles when entering a site
which was definitely a step in the right
direction
but in march another valerant underdog
got some buffs
viper became a real character and all of
a sudden
the meta on ice box began to change marv
tossing over that healing orb for baby
bay that jet
be nice and topped off the spike yet to
be planted 40 seconds make it 35.
on the clock and everybody's come on
over there's the spike down on the
ground and t1
they're working with their sixth man
being the clock here inside the cloud
burst finally automatic will fall with
just a frenzy in hand
but so much respect maybe too much given
one spider finally to fall maybe being
forced to use the daggers there's the
fight first bit and curry
clutches the thrifty round and pushes t1
to matt point
viper's toxic screen ability allowed
teams to secure plants on both sides of
the map
and the change in team compositions gave
icebox more of an identity
almost overnight icebox became a
different map it wasn't a place for the
brute force tactics we saw at first
strike
teams began to use more strategy face
trying to claw back into this game
nice fighter wall though will allow team
one to come forward
automatic swinging in with curry for a
quick three frags spiders lives in
behind as well
and they have been absolutely demolished
in the retake
t1 only losing one player on their way
to this spike that used to go
up to 10 rounds was icebox actually as
bad as everyone made it out to be
was shroud right the whole time was
every single
valerant player just blind to the truth
how does that even
happen well it's because shroud saw the
map's true potential while other players
didn't want to put in the time to learn
how to play it properly so i think it's
kind of an
a problem where we're just stubborn i
think it's more of a culture thing like
if you don't like it right away or you
don't want to adjust you don't take the
reps into doing it you just ban it and
you just say
because you ban it because you're not
good at it you say [ __ ] that map that
map blows
at this point even the pros have changed
their mind about icebox
i mean i enjoyed the map now it's it's
getting better um
the more you play it and then with the
agents um i think the big thing that
changed in the name
was the agents that were being played it
made the map a lot better when you're
playing like two duelists
and omen and like something else um
like killjoy i don't know it leaves the
map to be a lot more barren and dry but
then with viper it makes them a lot more
better interesting um
so it works out like that where like
once we got better agents to play like
the map more correctly and properly
the map became a lot better and more
recently with the release of breeze
riot has shown that they're willing to
continue making these larger more
experimental maps
just because vallen started as a copy of
counter-strike doesn't mean the two
games have to be identical
valrant actually needs icebox the game
was never going to survive as a clone of
cs go that's why riot added agent
abilities and made maps like breeze and
icebox
they needed to give their game an
identity of its own it's kind of boring
running around the same flat plane
and everyone's got their cross their
head level uh
i think it's cool and although the map
had its fair share of haters early on
icebox helped valrant get away from all
the cs comparisons
ice box was the first truly valerant map
and while some people still hate it for
being weird and different
it's become a staple of pro play nitrous
is going to immediately stick
for at least half of this he's going to
stand up maybe for a little bit longer
but as he does this luminosity
who were able to pick up the pieces a
bit of a flank coming over this is
awesome to try to make his way in
finds the first kill a bit of panic but
things will calm down for just a moment
now a 1v1 razon raise
showstopper flashback over the top no
asuna blindly
takes down feet goes aggressively dashes
his way across
lucio already with three but six oh sick
gets two
give him the third he is keeping
sentinels in this thing it's going to
drop down to a 1v1
as he waits to see if anyone's going to
rotate over pocky
coffee has a chance here but sick has
the luxury of weighing it out of 4k
for sick sentinels get to match point
now artists gonna find link on the way
back in
liquid already trying to play deeper
keep your eyes on the mini map look at
that flank coming through once again
from scream
see if they can buy the time for him to
be as much of a nuisance as he was
before artists
[Music]
players might not have been ready for a
map like icebox but by now
it's obvious that it was only a good
thing for the health of the game
and hell it might even be the best map
in valerian right now
this guy
yeah he's at the nonsense oh no you
missed it
defenders
that's so stupid